we've been looking at superannuation for
days done right and I think I first
serve baby was our nice stock standard
question I think I said there was a man
but let's skim a name because you know
it's nice a big rabbit
let's call Johnny because there's no
Johnny's and ah gum Johnny Kwai just
because there's a gentleman in last view
anyway okay now we said at the beginning
right what we started we said he was
going to regularly invest a certain
amount right he was gonna get it at a
certain mm interest rate and I think we
also said he was going to a percent
enough time right and then our question
was okay - we work out a final value at
the end the total value of this kind of
investment in a superannuation scheme
all right and think we've got something
like $37,000 or there abouts now -
remember the next thing I asked you was
we changed the question around right we
said okay supposing if he ended up with
thirty four dozen old suppose you want
to bother that supposed to 150 okay
how long would it take to do that so I
was I was sort of eliminating this
factor here I was giving you a different
piece of information so you can see
there's four bits and if you've got
three you can work out the last one
right the missing pitch okay now did you
get this let's have a go on working
through this if you think our nose is
what I want to end up with okay then
that's going to be equal to whatever we
had over here before okay if you go back
to the previous where you worked the
question we have the amount that was
regularly invested multiplied by now
what is always over here this is going
to be the series right and we took the
sum of the GP we had that over
I think we have 0.08 times just doing it
from memory so we tell you it's not me
in the wrong now of course this is in
the scenario where we had the 20 years
right but right now we've changed the
question and we've said we don't know
how many years there are it's an
indeterminate number of years so we'll
just call it in and that's what we're
trying to find okay all right yeah I the
hard work has already sort of been set
up right because we've done this
question already and we've already got
this piece here okay
so now if I want to work out n is just
one of them so I just have to do a
little bit of work to get and is the
subject right yeah so if I take all of
these numbers here and get your
calculator out and instead of having one
little write inside I want the bit on
the left
okay so I'll get my 50 really and I
guess I will multiply by 0.08 on the top
and divide by this number on the bottom
is that okay and what all that do that
really is yeah nothing okay now who's
who's rocket by the way remember yeah
what none do we get for point something
right for point skip to step time skip
steps yeah okay good all right now we'll
just put that number for now as you guys
know if we if we went with 4.04 and
there's you know a whole bunch of
decimal places off the idea that could
be okay or it might not be depending on
what these numbers end up being it could
introduce an error that might cause a
problem for us later so you guys know
you want to take that value and you want
to save it into your calculator so you
can use the exactly later one okay all
right now see is that's 1.08 to power of
n minus one and always on through the
brackets before I want the N so I guess
I'll kick that one over to the side so
I'll have I'll make
for them inside and so on and then you
get to this point and we actually gave
you questions like this years ago and
what you had to resort to was on trial
and error because it's kind of like I I
can't simply divide my CV or multiply by
something to get to the end but of
course you guys are going past that and
we know that this is called
locks right so this is an equation in
the index form if I can rewrite it in
logarithmic form I can make it in the
subject right so n is going to be equal
to and again trying to skip step two
it's just extra places for errors to be
introduced we log base now you've got to
get back to your box and try and
remember how to rewrite this the way I
remember it is the power is what we're
after so that's why it becomes the
subject right that's why we're using
logs in the first place when you're
thinking about which which number goes
on the basic which one goes on the top
and the base here will be the base from
the original base to this so I'll have
1.0 a down here okay so uh how do I look
at that we've got no log base 1.0 a on
our calculator unfortunately so again
you've got to go back to your log rules
think about which one do we want here
yeah change of this so you can choose
any base you like through these songs
it's the same I'm just going to go for
basically because I have to walk right
one less letter and the top number will
become the top of that here and the
bottom of our base
okay you go now Maggie yeah what we get
it should be 20 okay now what is telling
us what this means is that if we could
freeze an instantaneous point I'm 23 and
like an eighth of the way through the
year that's the point at which we would
hit our 50,000 okay except you remember
from the original question right how
frequently did we
interest on how frequently to contact
because annually right and we sort of
did that and many questions we do that
just to keep the numbers simple just so
that this thing doesn't begin they're
not being divided by 365 or what's fun
so but that means that it affects our
answer here if it's par waiting through
the 23rd yard that I actually hit 50
gram right I don't actually get paid
back so for instance if you went back to
this equation okay and just don't ignore
the narrator for a second and put it n
equals 23 just actually try to get your
calculator out on if n is equal 23
what's your what's your total value
equal to let's call it t let's go what
are you actually yeah
49,000 how much 323 right okay so that's
why we've got this extra point 1 5 here
to get that extra set of dollars right
except we don't get any of that extra
money until the very end of the year
that is okay so when you get that that's
the day we go to we should pass 50/50
and 1 700 800 just to sell figure and
there you are
now the reason why I enjoy this out is
because you often yeah confuses some of
these questions
oh all right wait what really I NFL
actually because it's got point out of
the years ago
okay so the reason why I put this out is
because some terms of your heart
sometimes you go down get confusing
later when we were looking at rather
than investing money trying to pay off
money again it's a little confusing so
if you actually have your values that
you are well here I haven't got my 50
gram and if you write all right so my
final answer Johnny
421 all right so final amount as a
question here this amount okay or time
as a question
we'll go for values right so can you
guess what's next
dry yourself up a table for me four
columns
let's put our four values here our
variables if you like down let's try and
get something systematic única so first
we can have T which is the total value
or the final value okay that was the
first question we asked and then we gave
you all the other pieces right the next
question we might ask is time now I
iteration I suppose because it's
actually a number of years right and it
tends to be the customer
Primula from there okay so I'm going to
call it M for duration number number of
time periods
I guess doesn't have to be using to be
months or anything now of course the
other two things we've got are the
amount that he regularly invests so I'll
call that a the regular investment
amount and the last one is the interest
rate so I'm going to call that are all
right okay yeah let's actually just do
this out because we've got some values
for this right just as examples before
we gave time we gave the amount and we
gave you strength and then we ended up
it thirty-seven thousand roughly yeah
just how we worked out if we change this
value right change it to 50 grand then
we have to go for longer right when you
for this they say at the same regular
investment and the same interest rate
okay so we're looking at this time you
feel that's why we're trying to work out
Dave this one sir
why don't we had to go at this one what
we said you know poor Johnny he got like
here
diagnosed with cancer or something it's
like I'm not gonna hang around for 24
years I need to go with my original
20-year plan because some reason might
give a dime 20 years so if we said I
still need for some mysterious reason
$15,000 and unlimited to 20 years okay
and this institution has no no
compassion on meters by the fact that I
have totaled heads up its to just going
to give you a percent so my question is
okay how much am I going to have to
change my regular investment each year
so that I could my time okay so where
you have anything about that give it a
go and then we'll come back to you after
you